[Applaudissements]
mesdames messieurs les maires mes chers
collègues je vais d'abord me tourner
vers vous madame la maire de paris cher
à nidal go vous dire que il y a deux
jours il y a trois jours nous étions
avec nos amis et collègues ultramarins
accueilli en ce magnifique hôtel de
ville d'une grande capitale dont nous
avons besoin et je veux dire à quel
point il est précieux que la maire de
paris son équipe en tout temps en tout
lieu toutes circonstances à porte la
contribution au soutien des négociations
que nous demandons des revendications
que nous portons
il n'y a pas une france son pari il n'ya
pas paris sont ces communes vous êtes là
nous sommes ensemble merci pour tout
je voudrais monsieur le président du
sénat par un tropisme bien naturel de la
salle on s'adresse à l'assistance à 6 et
puis le président de sénart et dans le
dos alors je me retourne d'un mouvement
le moins inélégant possible pour lui
dire à quel point la constance de la
permanence de son engagement pour nos
travaux la constance et la permanence de
son engagement dans nos commissions la
constance et la permanence de son
engagement dans nos départements qui n'a
pas vu gérard lâcher cette année dans
son département est quasiment dans sa
commune qui ne mesure pas à quel point
sa passion pour nos communes
car il est l'un des nôtres à nîmes
chevillée au corps sa responsabilité
élevée en sa qualité de président du
sénat je veux dire au sénat combien sur
soutien nous est précieux je veux dire à
quel point l'engagement personnel et
particulier du président larcher est
indispensable je veux dire à quel point
la délégation collectivités
territoriales de la haute assemblée
accompagne nos réflexions et je veux
dire à quel point c'est toujours une
joie un plaisir en responsabilité en
amitié chargé rares lâcher de se
retrouver ici pour conclure les travaux
du congrès des maires de france
merci à mesdames messieurs les
parlementaires ici largement présent et
je veux saluer la présence de dominique
bussereau président de l'assemblée des
départements de france qui a aux côtés
d'hervé morin président des régions de
france et de moi même il y a quelques
semaines à marseille lancé l'appel pour
une revanche de la décentralisation
dominique nous marchons main dans la
main à présent alors que nous étions
presque séparés par un mur de glace pas
tous les deux mais nos collectivités
territoriales presque plus difficile à
franchir que celui de game of thrones
même avec un dragon volant qui était
parti de l'autre côté de l'inconnu il
fallait beaucoup d'élan pour y parvenir
c'est vrai que depuis 82 globalement les
régions les départements les communes se
sont soit regarder en chiens de faïence
dans le meilleur des cas soit tirer le
tapis sous les pieds pour récupérer ici
une fiscalité là une compétence pour la
première fois monsieur le premier
ministre vous avez en face de vous ce
qui est une chance
de notre point de vue qui peuvent être
désagréables à certains égards les
régions et les départements et les
communes de france pour vous offrir un
acte iii de la décentralisation
le prieur de la république hier
lorsqu'il nous a réunis nous a fait
l'honneur de nous recevoir à l'hôtel
marigny à côté l'elysée a ouvert le jeu
sur l'acte iii bex décentralisation
ce congrès doit être le lancement de
l'acte iii de la décentralisation
ce congrès doit être la projection vers
une initiative puissante qui permettra
de répondre de la meilleure manière
possible à l'amélioration du coin de la
rue de chaque française et de chaque
français dans chaque commune de france
pour pousser loin les vents mauvais des
populismes qui sont en train de
déstabiliser l'ensemble de démocratie
global occidentale et mondial
[Applaudissements]
nous vous tendons la main le président a
offert la sienne je souhaite que nous
puissions marcher ensemble dans l'année
qui vient pour avancer sur ce chemin en
ce début de séance solennelle je
voudrais que nous ayons une pensée toute
particulière pour nos compatriotes de
métropole et d'outre-mer qui ont
affronté cette année des épreuves
exceptionnels liés notamment aux
attentats terroristes aux événements
climatiques majeurs je voudrais que nous
rendions hommage au dévouement de tous
les maires au rôle irremplaçable des
communes de france dans ces
circonstances en évoquant à l'instar
daniel algo symboliquement devant vous
l'année tragique a traversé une commune
la commune de trèbes dans l'aude frappé
d'abord par une attaque terroriste du 23
mars dernier dans lequel trois personnes
avaient trouvé la mort dont le
lieutenant-colonel arnaud beltrame
nombreuses sont les communes de france
monsieur le premier ministre qui ont
donné leur nom à une place à une rue à
une avenue à ce héros français au
courage exemplaire
c'était cette année c'était si loin on
ne doit pas oublier l'oubli push trop
vite sur les mémoires et sur les
consciences
je veux dire que la commune de trèbes
quelques semaines plus tard a été touché
gravement dans des inondations qui ont
provoqué la mort de 14 personnes
voilà un maire une équipe municipale
confronté un désarroi immense à des
désastres personnel et a une cicatrice
qui s'inscrira gagés sur l'éternité dans
les mémoires des générations qui se
suivront dans cette commune voilà aussi
le quotidien des maires de france
voilà aussi les raisons pour lesquelles
je souhaitais que le congrès des maires
de france puisse saluer notre collègue
éric ménassi son équipe municipale pour
lé dévouement exemplaire qui est le sien
qui traduit la hauteur de la dignité de
la fonction de ce qu est un maire et
qu'à travers lui soit touché aussi et
honorer toutes les équipes municipales
de notre pays qui font preuve d'un
engagement total au service de leur peau
citoyens aux côtés de tous les services
de secours
aux côtés de tout le réseau associatif
aux côtés de la solidarité aux côtés de
l'esprit d'intérêt général aux côtés
tout simplement de l'honneur d'une
république qui malgré les événements se
tient debout aux côtés de l'état pour
regarder droit devant et regarder un
avenir plus radieux que cette année 2018
je suis heureux au nom de nos instances
de rendre cet hommage devons vous
monsieur le premier ministre auquel le
président de la république a demandé de
bien vouloir leur présenter pour notre
champ 1e congrès je vous souhaite
sincèrement la bienvenue et nous
attendons évidemment avec impatience le
cadre général de la feuille de route que
l'état va porter et dont je ne doute pas
que vous allez développer le meilleur
des scénarios
les membres de votre gouvernement ayant
respecté la consigne extrêmement
professionnelle qui avait été indiqué ne
rien dire attendre rencontrons le
président de la république et discutons
ensemble
aucun de nos congrès ne se ressemble
aucun mais chacun s'inscrit dans une
actualité très particulière chaque
congrès des maires de france et leur
fait d'état du pays
il ya dans d'autres pays un discours à
la nation il est en france tous les ans
un congrès des maires de france qui
permet de faire le point sur ce que nous
disent nos administrés et sur la manière
dont les relations s'écrivent avec
l'état nous sommes par définition
ensemble au service de la république
mais chaque congrès est un événement lui
même parce qu'à aucun autre moment de
notre vie publique ne sont rassemblés
autant d'acteurs majeurs de la vie
quotidienne de la république
c'est ainsi depuis toujours les communes
sur le socle de la république
les maires sont les garants de la
démocratie locale et depuis 110 ans
l'association des maires de france
les rassemblent dans leur diversité
politique dans leur diversité
géographique territoriale et surtout
humaine notre mission n'a pas varié nous
portons la voie des communes sans esprit
partisan
nous essayons de concilier tous les
points de vue qui font notre richesse et
notre légitimité et dans notre longue
histoire monsieur le premier ministre
nous avons été en accord ou en désaccord
avec à peu près toutes les majorités
donc soyez apaisé
il n'y a pas grand chose de nouveau sur
le front de notre réunion d'aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
je les dis l'an dernier il faut jamais
négliger l'histoire est toujours se
poser sur quelques sujets qu'il soit la
question de savoir d'où ça vient et
pourquoi pourquoi il ya eu un congrès
des maires de france et d'où est il venu
il est venu de la suppression d'une taxe
par l'état qui est l octroi des communes
pour financer les caisses des communes
et où est il allé jusqu'à aujourd'hui
d'une certaine manière pour dénoncer à
nouveau le point d'interrogation
soulevées par la suppression d'une taxe
celle de l'habitation pour financer les
services publics que nous produisions au
quotidien un siècle s'est écoulé toutes
les majorités succès se sont succédé
soutenant des gouvernements y compris
ceux auxquels nous avons appartenu andré
laignel et moi même et nous avons tous
en mémoire le cadre général de la
tension qui pouvaient exister avoir des
désaccords c'est pas très grave
les avoir sur des sujets de fond ça fait
partie du débat politique les avoir en
revanche sur des préoccupations de forme
il faut tourner cette page là vous voyez
en dessous de ce pupitre et juste
derrière moi il y à un hashtag ce à
chaque c'est ma commune j'y tiens il ya
un mois monsieur le premier ministre
dans l'anonymat des réseaux sociaux a
été lancé un autre
hashtag balances ton maire balances ton
maire hashtag mondiale référencé pour
dénoncer les hommes commettant des
délits des crimes des violences contre
des femmes on est dans un monde de
communication cette référence cibler
directement des criminels et des
délinquants qui d'autre peut comprendre
autrement
l'initiative relayée par des membres qui
soutiennent votre majorité dans le cadre
global de la vindicte jeter à l'opinion
publique à travers ce hashtag les
regrets
les regrets exprimés je vous le dis ne
change rien à la violence de l'intention
à son irresponsabilité et à son
injustice profonde une injustice
profonde à l'égard d'hommes et de femmes
qui par delà leurs différences en commun
la passion de la france et l'engagement
au service des françaises et des
français et qu'on me comprenne bien au
delà nos personnes qui ne font que
passer
c'est la république qui a été abîmée
presque dans tous les sens du terme
habib mais ça veut dire fatigue est
abîmée ça veut dire aussi c'est chou et
les deux doivent être à l'opposé de ce
que nous incarnons et de ce que nous
portons les deux doit être restaurée
dans l'année qui vient pour un dialogue
fécond à la hauteur des enjeux que nous
portons cette montée des populismes que
nous évoquions à l'instant est un
phénomène mondial
il déstabilise toutes les institutions
il est d'ailleurs assez singulier
d'observer dans les violences constatées
depuis presqu'une semaine en france à
travers le mouvement des gilet jaune
les deux institutions monsieur le
premier ministre qui sont attaqués c'est
la préfecture et l'hôtel de ville ça
veut bien dire que nous avons destin lié
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
vous soutenons
pour garantir l'ordre dans chaque
commune de france
mais comment prétendre combattre ces
populisme est versée à corps perdu dans
ses actions qui leur donne de la force
cinq jours après le début de cette
campagne contre nous le romain millions
dhs ministériel était placée sous le
signe d'un nouveau dialogue avec les
collectivités locales
nous en prenons acte positivement mais
la question des personnes au fond un
porte - de la politique qui va être
conduite dans les semaines et dans les
mois qui viennent si cette nouvelle
équipe chargée du dialogue avec nous n'a
pour l'instant aucun mandat pour
négocier sur des sujets importants
d'ordre financiers aux institutionnels
par exemple les échanges n'iront pas
très loin c'est normal ça a été le cas
avec tous les gouvernements qui
n'avaient pas une feuille de route
claire nul et on touche pris notre part
pour réussir le dialogue
il est nécessaire de tirer les
conséquences de l'échec de la conférence
nationale des territoires en fait c'est
100 et elle a échoué parce qu'elle n'a
été ni une instance de concertation ni
une instance de négociation
il n'y a pas eu de concertation lorsque
le président de la république nous a
annoncé le jour même de l'ouverture et
de l'intronisation de 700 et le passage
de l'effort financier demandé aux
collectivités de 10 à 13 milliards
il n'y a pas eu de concertation lorsque
la décision de réduire brutalement le
nombre des emplois aidés a été prise il
n'y a pas eu de concertation lorsque les
agences de l'eau et les organismes de
logement social ont été privés d'une
partie de leurs ressources
il n'a pas eu de vraie concertation sur
le plan pauvreté dont la mise en oeuvre
va pourtant reposer en grande partie sur
les collectivités et singulièrement sur
les communes il n'y a pas eu de
concertation sur la décision
d'abandonner les propositions de jean
louis borloo sur lesquels nous avions
tous travailler je veux d'ailleurs
rendre hommage à tous les élus tous les
acteurs de terrain et toutes les
associations qui ont consacré beaucoup
de temps à ce travail pour un rapport
qui finit encore une fois dans un tiroir
et sur la conférence nationale des
territoires vous le savez monsieur le
premier ministre nous en avons discuté
les signaux d alerte ont été nombreux et
nous avons pas été les seuls à les
envoyer les régions avaient été les
premières à quitter pu réintégrer la
table nous étions venus à cahors en
observateur et finalement cher dominique
bussereau sont les départements qui ont
tiré la nappe mais ils n'ont pas tiré
pour changer le couvert il en tire est
parce que la discussion avec l'état sur
une politique fondamentale
qui vise à apporter le cadre général de
l'accompagnement financier sur la
problématique douloureuse et humaine des
mineurs isolés concerne tout le monde
lorsque les départements en détention
avec l'état sur cette politique
d'accompagnement des mineurs isolés
mineurs isolés dont la mission est une
mission de nature régaliennes c'est à
l'état qu'il appartient de négocier de
définir dans le cadre européen
le nombre de mineurs isolés dans un flou
qui est important mais c'est aux
départements et aux conseils
départementaux de financer ses
politiques telles que la
décentralisation la proposer plus d'un
milliard trois ne sont pas payés par
l'état à l'égard des départements on
peut comprendre la difficulté des
discussions dans un contexte budgétaire
difficile mais d'abord pourquoi nous
sommes nous pas associée alors que
derrière qui inscrit les jeunes dans les
écoles c'est nous les maires qui
débloque les aides d'urgence dans les
centres municipaux d'action sociale pour
les accompagner dans des politiques de
précarité difficile au quotidien qui
essaient de trouver des places dans les
centres d'hébergement qui essayent de
négocier avec les bailleurs sociaux pour
trouver des places pour les familles qui
les rejoignent sur les mers nous avons
partie liée nous avons destin lié et
donc lorsque les départements à juste
titre ont manifesté dans un premier
temps un étonnement et dans un deuxième
mouvement un sentiment au fond d'absence
des coups tu nous as dommen lorsque les
départements nous ont demandé la
solidarité nous avons dit oui tout de
suite parce que la cause est juste parce
que nous travaillons main dans la main
sur les politiques sociales de proximité
et avoir une lecture statistiques ou
budgétaires des politiques sur le qui
fait quoi où les régions ne s'occuperait
que de l'aménagement des territoires et
les départements que des politiques
sociales et nous que des services
publics de proximité c'est ne rien
comprendre à l'organisation des
territoires
nous travaillons tous ensemble et sur
l'aménagement du territoire et sur le
développement économique et sur la
politique de développement
d'enseignement supérieur et sur le cadre
des politiques sociales de proximité et
sur la politique de logement et sur la
politique d'accompagnement des tissus
associatif et pour le développement du
sport et pour le développement de la
culture
nous sommes en partie les
co-responsables les acteurs et même les
acteurs majeurs du fonctionnement
publiques du pays
et c'est bien la raison pour laquelle il
nous fallait
prendre la décision d'être solidaire aux
côtés des départements et les régions
l'ont fait de même pour vous adresser un
message fort et puissant de l'impasse
dans laquelle nous allions rentrer il
manquait aussi à la conférence nationale
des territoires peut être une envie de
négocier ou peut-être qu'elle a été mal
formaté c'est à dire de trouver des
solutions qu'ils aient vocation à être
portée par tous les acteurs de la
démocratie locale en même temps que
l'état les maires que vous avez en face
de vous n'ont aucune envie d'être en
face à face
ils ont tous les jeux aux envies d'être
pauthe à côte avec le préfet avec les
services de l'état pour réussir au
quotidien lutte est justement pour la
désespérance sociale
nous en sommes portable et nous sommes
conscients de nos désaccords et lorsque
nous avons constaté nos désaccords
l'état a mis en oeuvre en fait ce qu'il
avait décidé seul et il s'étonnait que
nous contestions ces décisions alors je
sais pas si vous connaissez la formule
est très simple
cet animal est méchant quand on lui
donne un coup de pied quand on l'attaqué
il se défend c'est quand une curieuse
façon de concevoir la vie lorsque nous
avons des désaccords et que nous disons
et bien c'est pas une réaction violente
ou une agression insupportable à l'écart
d'un état tout puissant c'est tout
simplement le sentiment non seulement de
ne pas avoir été écouté mais d'avoir été
abondé abandonné juste avant l'été sur
le pas de la route sans pouvoir avoir
son mot à dire dans cette situation
alors lorsque l'état fait le choix d'un
parcours solitaire
nous proposons de travailler à des
solutions désormais partager ça veut
dire que chacun doit faire un pas vers
l'autre et toute la relation entre nous
et à reconsidérer sous l'angle de la
confiance qui ne peut se décréter qui ne
peut que se fait condé au jour le jour
mais d'une confiance réciproque si la
concertation est conduite comme une
obligation comme une case à cocher sans
réelle intention pour le gouvernement de
richir ses projets de ceux qui lui ai
dit alors c'est certain
rien ne pourra progresser et nous sommes
respectueux des pouvoirs publics dont
nous n'avons jamais contesté la
légitimité mais nous avons aussi le
droit d'avoir une opinion et la mettre
dans le débat démocratique sans pour
autant être soupçonné de chercher à
nuire l'action de la majorité c'est pas
notre sujet et on ne souhaite que la
réussite de notre pays
que les choses soient très claires nous
n'avons jamais hésité au nom de la mmf à
nous opposer à nos propres familles
politiques
lorsque cela nous paraissait justifié ce
qui nous intéresse c'est le fond des
dossiers palais qu'une des polémiques
parce que nous sommes des élus
responsables et passionnés par notre
mandat parce que nous avons des équipes
compétentes et qui travaille depuis
toujours avec l'ensemble de vos
ministères et parce que notre seule
ambition est de bien servir les communes
dont nous avons la faiblesse de penser
et probablement aussi la force d'y
croire qu'elles sont utiles à la
république nous savons et nous l'avons
prouvé par le passé travailler
positivement et soutenir sans a priori
des mesures lorsque par exemple ministre
de l'intérieur signe la semaine dernière
une circulaire aux préfets améliorant ce
qui est important est ce que nous avions
de mode et l'information des maires sur
les risques de radicalisation sur nos
territoires dans l'évolution de la
menace terroriste dans chaque commune de
france la menace terroriste elle et pas
qu'à paris ou dans les grandes
métropoles
elle peut être vécu ou traverser dans
chaque commune eh bien lorsque il y à
cette amélioration
nous faisons connaître notre
satisfaction nous l'avons dit nous
l'avons dit d'autant plus volontiers que
nous avons été associés de longue date à
l'élaboration du texte qui a été produit
lorsque les ministres de l'éducation
nationale de la justice ou de
l'intérieur nous associe aux mesures
destinées à sécuriser les écoles nous
apportons notre contribution avec
sérieux et nous sommes sur un bon chemin
lorsque les ministres la santé d'égalité
part sur une direction au départ qui ne
nous semble pas la bonne nous en avons
discuté
l'affectation des places de crèches dans
les communes
le postulat était d'imaginer un véhicule
législatif considérant qu'il y avait
trop de brouillard dans la gestion de
ces places de crèche nourrissant par là
même un peu plus la suspicion à l'égard
des élus sur une forme de clientélisme à
travers l'affectation de ces places de
crèche
qu'avons nous fait nous avons alerté les
ministres je suis allait mal et moi même
voir madame busin et madame schiappa l
on écoute et on a mis en place un groupe
de travail
on a défini un vade-mecum un guide de
bonnes pratiques à la disposition de
toutes les communes mises à la
disposition de l'opinion publique pour
bien montrer la sincérité du cadre
réglementaire de l'affectation
de place d'un service public dont je
rappelle qu'il est facultatif lorsque le
secrétaire d'état à la cohésion des
territoires s'implique sur le plan
d'envergure de développement du
numérique ce qui va vraiment dans la
bonne direction et associer les
collectivités territoriales à sa mise en
oeuvre
nous l'avons soutenu et nous l'avons
aidé je pourrais multiplier les exemples
dans le domaine des finances de
l'environnement de la culture du sport
ou de la fonction publique il y a eu des
secteurs sur lesquels nous avons bien
avancé mais sur le fond nous avons
évidemment été amenés à ralentir
tout simplement parce que nous avons
parfois eu le sentiment de ne pas être
respecté
lorsque nous avons défendu les emplois
aidés
on nous a répondu qu'on était des
clientéliste comme si on allait acheter
des voix alors que il faut ne jamais
avoir été confrontés à la précarité
sociale dans une permanence d'élu local
pour ne pas savoir que souvent l'emploi
aidé c'est la dernière bouée de
sauvetage pour des personnes qui sont
dans la grande misère et c'est la main
tendue pour trouver le chemin d'une
insertion sociale et personnelle
lorsque la mesure apl a été mise en
oeuvre de notre point de vue une mesure
strictement budgétaire nous n'avons pas
été associés suffisamment à
l'accompagnement du cadre général des
conséquences pour les offices publics de
l'habitat les conséquences elles sont là
elles sont déjà chiffré nous le savons
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
logements ne seront pas produits en 2018
comme c'était prévu et ce qui est
annoncé après 2020 est beaucoup plus
préoccupant encore puisque
l'investissement dans la réhabilitation
de ces quartiers est aujourd'hui en cale
sèche
la politique de l'anru ne peut être pas
sur le plan d'adaptation budgétaire
d'accompagner le développement de ces
quartiers le rapport borloo a été
enterré nous l'avons vu est donc la
politique de la ville est aujourd'hui un
gros point d'interrogation
la production de logements sociaux est
plus qu'incertaine et entraîne par me
l'a même la raréfaction de la production
de logements privés
il va falloir là aussi réfléchir me
semble-t-il à une discussion plus
ouverte sur comment on relance le
logement en france mais dans le même
temps parallèle on lance un plan
pauvreté 60 % des apl son niveau des
minima sociaux et de précarité
ça veut dire que en ayant baissé la paix
l on pense réduire la pauvreté dans un
cadre d'un plan global
je pense que là aussi il faut en
discuter je pense que là aussi nous
devons en reparler en profondeur
tout cela nous l'avons dit hier soir à
l'invitation du président de la
république en votre présence en la
présence de madame gouro de monsieur le
corps nu qui sont à vos côtés pour
restaurer ce dialogue avec les
collectivités territoriales et nous
l'avons dit de manière puissamment et
profondément républicaines de part et
d'autre puissamment et profondément
courtoise c'est normal nous respectons
l'éducation qui nous a été transmise et
puis il ya aussi un sentiment de
complicité affronter difficultés au
quotidien que nous avons également en
partage et nous l'avons dit aussi avec
beaucoup de franchise comme nous le
faisons aujourd'hui car au fond ces
discussions doivent être à livre ouvert
est ce que nous avons dit au président
de la république nous le restitue sont
devant vous avec beaucoup de fidélité
les changes a été utile naturellement il
est pas tout à fait de la même nature et
vous le savez une invitation a été
lancée au président de la république qui
a pris l'engagement de nous faire
l'honneur de venir l'année prochaine et
nous nous en félicitons
c'était un bon échange et c'était un bon
débat et je crois à l'engagement et la
sincérité la tâche est difficile
elle est difficile pour nous elle est
immensément difficile pour ceux qui
servent l'état et elle letter évidemment
encore plus pour le chef de l'état
mais l' écoute sera certainement le
meilleur des remèdes et qui ne sera pas
un placebo pour permettre justement à
l'état aux services publics aux pouvoirs
publics
au fond à la république de s'appuyer sur
les mers que nous sommes pour lutter
plus efficacement pour ceux qui la
contestent
parmi les engagements pris par le
président de la république il y en avait
un qui tenait à coeur de beaucoup de
mères c'était l'engagement de ne pas
priver par exemple de manière brutale et
unilatérale certaines communes pour qui
c'était légitime de la compétence eau et
assainissement et ce qui a rendu
complexe nos discussions sur d'autres
sujets c'est que par exemple sur un
sujet qui ne fait l'objet a priori
d'aucune interrogation qu'est ce que ça
peut faire qu'un maire d'une petite
commune et la possibilité de conserver
le cadre général d'ouvrir ou de fermer
les robinets d'eau dans chacune des
communes qu'est ce que ça peut faire et
à titi ça peut ennuyer
en quoi c'est un problème politique sauf
à vouloir dépouiller les maires
totalement et définitivement du cadre
général de leur exercice de leur laisser
les chrysanthèmes
mais en général c'est plutôt quand on
est avancée au compteur de la vie et
leur laisser l'état civil et comme il ya
beaucoup moins de mariages et moins de
naissances dans les villages et bien
dans ce cas là le sentiment d'abandon et
le sentiment d'éloignement est encore
peu puissants leur quête du cevipof que
chacun connaît désormais montre la
réalité de ces sentiments douloureux et
et est délicat voilà un sujet concret
sur lequel on peut rouvrir le jeu j'ai
cru entendre j'ai cru comprendre que
cela pouvait faire partie des
discussions que nous pourrions avoir
avec les membres de votre gouvernement
je souhaite que nous puissions ouvrir le
jeu sur ce sur cette question
l'engagement sur ce point nous a
d'autant plus surpris que nous pensions
qu'il était ferme mais les débats au
parlement n'ont pas été soutenus par les
membres de votre majorité et je dois la
vérité de reconnaître et
et je dois au regret de le souligner
également que les membres du
gouvernement chargés de défendre
l'arbitrage présidentiel n'ont pas tout
à fait suivi ni l'esprit ni la lettre de
ce que nous avions peut-être à tort
compris comme le respect du cadre
général de l'application de la
responsabilité entre les communes et les
intercommunalités sur l'eau et
l'assainissement
nous avions eu un deuxième engagement
également sur l' agence des territoires
c'était une idée l'association des
maires de france
notre idéal était simple il fallait
créer une ans rue pour nos campagnes
pour notre ruralité une en russe est à
dire une agence dotée avec de l'argent
sonnant et trébuchant voté en loi de
finances qui avait fait la preuve de son
efficacité
un euro pour la ville un euro pour la
campagne
c'était une idée assez simple partage et
compréhensible par tous lagence et créer
matal être doté et est ce qu elle ne
s'éloigne pas à travers le cadre général
de l'esprit initial de ce que nous
souhaitions je pense que ça doit faire
partie là aussi de nos discussions
concrètes
parce que c'est un effet de levier
extraordinaire pour concentrer les
moyens de l'état afin d'optimiser les
services publics dans notre protection
globale dans la lettre qu'il a adressée
au maire cette semaine le président de
la république a exprimé sa satisfaction
d'avoir maintenu le niveau global de la
dgf
il est vrai que la loi de finances gel
la dgf
mais on ne peut pas ignorer que seize
mille sept cent quarante cinq communes
soit près de la moitié ont connu une
diminution de cette dotation sous
l'effet notamment de la baisse de la
dotation forfaitaire qui concerne plus
de 22000 comme hénin et on ne peut pas
non plus ignorer que 8000 commune en
peluche ont vu leurs dotations de
péréquation baissé ce n'est pas la
décision des parlementaires qui est en
cause ni même celle du gouvernement
c'est le cadre général qui fait que sur
le plan budgétaire on est resté dans une
enveloppe fermée et restant dans une
enveloppe fermée et bien la chute a été
libre et donc l'engagement pris de
l'absence de baisse de dotation pour
cette année comme les suivantes ne peut
pas être respectée puisque le système
global de péréquation créé les
conditions justement d'une chute libre
et donc d'un sentiment d'incompréhension
de la part des communes qui ont vu cette
chute alors que le message que nous
avions porté et relayé était exactement
à l'opposé
là encore la mf et êtes force de
proposition nous vous proposons la mise
en place d'un fonds de lissage pour
permettre au moins aux communes les plus
touchées par ces baisses de dotations de
pouvoir en étaler les effets dans le
temps
notre proposition les parlementaires de
la majorité sont ici a été rejeté à
l'assemblée sans débat je pense que là
encore nous avons une immense marge de
progression dans les discussions sur les
véhicules législatifs de nature
financière et budgétaire pour améliorer
le cadre général de ce qui est efficace
et de ce qui est utile pour nous nous
souhaitons qu'une étude d'impact soit
menée pour mesurer les conséquences de
la modification de la carte communale
sur la dgf pour l'année 2019
là aussi j'ai compris nous avons entendu
une ouverture était possible de la part
du président de la république ce cadre
fait partie du mandat de négociation qui
vient de nous être confiée pour la taxe
d'habitation cela était évoqué très
largement dans la motion
nous avons participé à des réunions de
discussion sur des sujets extrêmement
complexe chacun à vider la méthode en
elle même pouvait avoir sa pertinence
elle a achoppé sur le point qui est tout
simplement que nous ne ferons aucune
guerre au département et que nous ne
revendiquons pas le foncier bâti ou non
bâti pour compenser la taxe d'habitation
nous serons donc avec les départements
aux côtés des départements pour porter
une solution qui sera comme une région
département communes de france
celles ci portent la forme du
dégrèvement indexé sur l'évolution du
coût de la vie dans un cadre
garantissant des recettes et c'est pas
pour se faire plaisir
c'est derrière pour financer des
services publics c'est derrière pour
garantir les investissements de
développement de chaque territoire
quel est l'âge en économie qui peut
imaginer se développer s'il investit pas
personne pas une entreprise pas à
ménages quel est donc le territoire qui
peut imaginer se développer s'il a plus
les moyens d'investir
or le sentiment global c'est qu'à
travers la gestion de ces dotations et
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
il y aura plus rien pour investir et
comme l'état ne fait plus grand chose en
investissement et bien dans ce cas là
qui va investir plus personne c'est bien
ça le coeur de l'incompréhension et de
la préoccupation en profondeur de tous
les maires de france et de tous les élus
de france
le président de la république a ouvert
un autre chantier qui nous intéresse
beaucoup
celui de la révision de la loi
fondamentale et la révision de la
constitution
nous souhaitons consacrer la commune
dans la constitution
nous souhaitons consacrer dans notre loi
fondamentale la clause de compétence
générale
nous souhaitons toiletter l'article 72
de la constitution pour clarifier ce que
veut dire libre administration des
collectivités territoriales dans le
cadre défini par la loi
nous souhaitons faire vivre
constitutionnellement l'idée d'une
république décentralisée nous souhaitons
l'autonomie fiscale et nous souhaitons
l'autonomie financière
nous souhaitons tout simplement cet acte
iii de la décentralisation dont le
président de la république a considéré à
juste titre que c'était un débat utile
et intéressant pour le pays à travers la
révision de la loi fondamentale à
travers l'engagement des parlementaires
dans leur rôle de constituants il y a là
une fenêtre extraordinaire de
rassemblement national autour d'une idée
partagée par tous les bancs constituant
les formations politiques présentes à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat qu'il
pourrait être extraordinaire d'utiliser
dans le sens de la clarification et de
l'amélioration de nos relations et il
n'est pas douteux que dans une hypothèse
comme celle ci tous les présidents de la
république et tous les premiers
ministres ne pourront prononcer aucun
autre discours que d'écouter les
applaudissements et les acclamations
c'est un encouragement que sur le
premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
les autres sujets ont été largement
abordés
le chef de l'état nous a fait part de sa
volonté hier de resserrer les liens de
travail entre l'état et nous nous le
souhaitons de tout notre coeur de toute
notre énergie de toute notre passion de
servir comme nous comprenons également
la sienne de servir la france
nous sommes disponibles pour cela je
crois que vous l'avez compris à présent
il s'agit d'être associé le plus tôt
possible au projet du gouvernement est
de partager en toute transparence
selon le voeu du président les éléments
permettant de fonder les décisions nous
avons noté avec satisfaction son
intention d'ouvrir un certain de
chantier y compris financiers nous
voulons lui rappeler l'importance
d'apporter au premier semestre 2010 9
mais je crois que nous sommes déjà en
phase des réponses claires sur la
manière de compenser la taxe
d'habitation
c'est un sujet prioritaire et c'est
normal nous demandons au président de la
république dans l'esprit de dialogue
dont il nous a fait part de s'y
impliquer fortement et personnellement
au côté du gouvernement que vous dirigez
nous partageons la volonté du président
de la république de mieux associer les
élus aux réformes car nous sommes
convaincus que la république doit
avancer
unis nous sommes des acteurs nous sommes
des progressistes par nature on n'a
qu'une idée en tête chaque soir quand on
se couche quand on est maire de penser à
l'amélioration du coin de la rue du
quotidien du bien-être des administrés
c'est ça un maire erik orsenna plus
lettrés mais aussi géographe plein
d'allant
car une énergie sans faiblesse et
passionné de nos sujets ce qui nous
honorent le dirait certainement mieux
que mieux que moi et mieux que nous tous
mais cette idée de la petite patrie
cette idée de la grande famille
cette idée de la république en petit ou
en grand cette idée de la démocratie de
proximité cette idée de servir cette
idée de panser les plaies
cette idée d'être à l'écouté des plus
défavorisés
cette idée de ceux qui n'ayant pas ou
plus d'espoir pour se retourner vers
aucun membre de sa famille se tourner
vers la porte de la mairie et le bureau
du maire c'est ça la réalité notre
quotidien et le caractère féconder
échange avec les maires et toujours une
projection vers l'avenir et par
définition il n'y a aucun maire dans
cette salle comme en france qui
quoi ou qui puisse être considéré comme
un terrain corps intermédiaires
conservateur replié sur lui même est un
élément majeur d'une société bloquée
nous sommes les acteurs de tout le
contraire d'une société à l'ecoute
ouverte qui veut progresser et qui veut
progresser à l'unité dans une gestion de
plus en plus difficile du cadre général
du quotidien qui est imposée aux
français
alors mes chers amis mes chers collègues
monsieur le premier ministre nous
voulons croire qu'une nouvelle ère de
confiance entre l'état et nous va
s'ouvrir
nous y sommes des disposer car c'est la
tradition de la mf depuis toujours les
attentes des élus sont fortes elles
recoupent l'impatience du pays que le
président lui-même a évoqué nos
responsabilités sont immenses et
collectives de l'accès à l'emploi la
réduction des inégalités du
développement économique à la lutte
contre le changement climatique
nous serons des acteurs à vos côtés de
cette évolution le congrès s'achève
une page se tourne nous l'espérons d'un
chapitre qui aura été au cours de cette
année écrit à l'encré de
l'incompréhension à l'encré d'une
méthode incertaine à l'encré parfois de
mauvaises manières que nous souhaitons
pas relire pas l'année prochaine pas les
années suivantes par relire du tout ni
vous sûrement et je n'en doute pas ni
nous c'est certain vous l'avez compris
le congrès nous a confié un mandat de
négociation il est clair il est précis
nous allons le suivre fidèlement jusqu'à
l'année prochaine en monsieur le premier
ministre
comme le disait corneille ma pièce de
théâtre est terminée il ya plus qu'à
l'écrire